we're just getting some breaking news
coming to us out of Israel where Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and his main
rival Benny Gant's have just agreed to
form an emergency unity government let's
go straight over to Harry Fawcett he
joins us now live from West Jerusalem's
what does this government look like
exactly well it looks like one that
Bennigan's said was necessary in a time
of national emergency to fight the
coronavirus he of course was someone who
had dedicated his pretty short
political career or biet including three
consecutive inconclusive elections to
trying to unseat Benjamin Netanyahu but
he decided last month that he would join
him in a unity government but those
negotiations have been extremely rocky
ever since and there was a real danger
or for those who are against it a real
hope that they might fall apart
there was always the possibility that
Benny Gantz
might use the piece of leverage in his
back pocket that he did have available
which was at least allowing if not
sponsoring a bill which could have
legislated against someone facing
corruption charges as Benjamin Netanyahu
is from forming a government from
standing as Prime Minister had it gone
to a fourth election on the Netanyahu
side really I think there was a pretty
clear awareness that Benny Gant's had
put all of his eggs in the basket of a
unity government so that was a pretty
strong card for them to play they said
that they would abandon talks on a unity
government should Gantz go ahead with
trying to legislate Netanyahu out of
office one of the key stumbling blocks
was about judicial appointments
Netanyahu apparently extremely concerned
about the prospects of the High Court
ruling that he can't form a government
because of his indictments on corruption
in a trial due to start next month and
the blue and white of Benny GATS was
keen to ensure that it had some control
over those judicial appointments as well
and so all the while this has ostensibly
been about these two opposed factions
coming together in a time of national
emergency to fight the coronavirus these
are very personally important facts to
Benjamin Netanyahu and has been
to stay on as Prime Minister I've also
been there at the for the deal would see
him stay on for 18 months and then Ganz
would take over as Prime Minister after
that we wait to see of course if that
actually eventuates so just to be clear
here on some of those thorny issues when
it comes to the so called rotation deal
that's Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
staying on as you said for 18 months
what ultimately did they decide when it
comes to Netanyahu's demand for more
influence over judicial appointments
well we wait to hear the details of the
deal but there had been indications that
there has been this afternoon some kind
of agreement some sort of bridge made on
those issues so the detail of that has
yet to emerge also when it comes to the
rotational deal there had been leaks to
the media that Netanyahu was trying to
ensure that he could stay on in a very
influential role even after handing over
the Premiership to Bennigan's as would
under the terms of this arrangement be
the case in 18 months time as a deputy
there are concerns that perhaps he might
be ruled out of that position again
because these corruption charges that he
faces and so we wait to see exactly how
it all comes out in the wash all right
thanks so much Harry for sit there